why don't the feminists complain about
Saudi Arabia it's like you know God Saad
who's this guy at Concordia who is in a
business school so he can actually say
what he thinks now and then he tweeted
yesterday well he tweeted to the woman's
March you know because there's a little
Twitter thing you could do that I
suppose for the organizers he said why
don't you go to the Middle East and have
a nice march against Saudi Arabian Sea
see how that works out for you like so
you think well so why not like why not
why why are the wire there radical
leftists who are so much for rights
everywhere that's what they say why
aren't they complaining about Saudi
Arabia for example which you know breeds
a particularly pathological form of
ideologically rigid Islam that basically
enslaves their women that's to put it
properly it's like why not complain
about that well how about this the enemy
of my enemy is my friend
and so when push comes to shove you see
how much concern there is among the
radical feminists for the rights of
women it's like if the pushing those
rights forward doesn't also at the same
time under undermine the Western
patriarchy then we'll take the
undermining and leave the damn rights
behind and so there's an insight for you
about exactly what's going on at the
bottom of all this